on est tous horrifié par le véritable
calvaire qu'une enseignante de première
année a fait subir à ses élèves à
l'école primaire des grands vents à
sainte-mars-sur-le-lac hurlement menace
l'intimidation on vous présente quelques
secondes de cet enregistrement qui a mis
le feu aux poudres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait l'objet maintenant de quatre
plaintes dont trois pour votre fait le
directeur de l'école a été suspendu de
ses fonctions par le centre de service
scolaire des Mille-Îles sont
remplacement était réclamés par des
parents qui l'accusaient de ne pas avoir
fait son travail qui est l'accusait
littéralement de l'axisme écoutons
quelques réactions
des actions vraiment concrètes puis que
on sache vraiment le fond de l'histoire
depuis combien de temps réellement que
ça dure puis pourquoi qu'il y a pas une
mesure de mis en place depuis le temps
Éric compo c'est une personne
qui est un peu tolérant mais
tolérer des choses non c'est
inacceptable et tout comme trop tolérant
faut changer ce modèle-là qui fonctionne
pas on a les parents hier ils m'ont
demandé il demandait à qui qu'on puisse
plaindre et on peut confiance au centre
scolaire à qui qu'on puisse plaindre le
ministre a mis une fameuse ligne 1 800
il paraissent une boîte vocale il
faudrait valider mais
on se planquie il y a plus de
commissaire
alors je retrouve végétoyé je le
présentais tout à l'heure psychologue
des spécialiste de la réussite scolaire
bonsoir et Gilles de Royer écoutez la
question de l'imputabilité des
enseignants vous savez comme moi
monsieur Royer ça ne date pas d'hier on
a retrouvé une promesse de François
Legault
professionnel parce que tous les
professionnels ça soit des ingénieurs
des avocats même des infirmières des
comptables agréés ils ont tous un ordre
professionnel qui vient s'assurer
justement qu'un suivi qui soit fait de
la formation continue de la mise à jour
donc des connaissances des
professionnels les critères d'évaluation
vont être fixées avec leur professionnel
des enseignants
alors deuxième mandat du gouvernement
logo nouveau ministre de l'Éducation
Bernard drinville a dit aujourd'hui que
c'est pas dans les cartons alors c'est
pas une promesse qu'on entend respecter
monsieur Royer mais vous vous êtes un
fervent défenseur de cette idée-là
comment expliquez-vous la résistance de
Bernard drinville aujourd'hui
contrairement à une question
une question de
réaction syndicale et c'est pour ça
qu'on voulait absolument dissocier ce
qui relève des conditions de travail ni
négociations au niveau du travail de ce
qui relève la profession
psychologue scolaire
orthophoniste
psycho-éducateur sont syndiqués mais
notamment professionnel j'aurais tenu
dans mes écoles dans 10 écoles primaires
où j'ai travaillé j'aurais tenu ce
discours là qui est de l'agression
verbale une forte professionnelle grave
il y aura une plainte directement que
les parents ont repris déposer alors des
psychologues et ça reste suivi et là on
a enlevé la dimension syndicale
patronale direction on touche
directement la profession et en ce qui
concerne moi j'ai écouté je participe au
comité vers 96 qui a étudié la première
demande pour l'ordre des enseignants il
y a au moins trois recommandations qui
sont sorties en disant que ce soit une
association professionnelle ou un ordre
professionnel
le qui est-ce qu'on admet dans la
profession l'admission l'exercice
l'évaluation de l'encadrement de la
pratique d'enseignement et la
surveillance disciplinaire écoutez ça
c'est le minimum et dans la province
voisine les enseignants sont syndiqué et
membres d'un autre professionnel et
écouter je suis certain d'avoir les
réactions que j'ai eu moi aussi par
rapport aux plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui suivent et qui me suivent
sur les réseaux sociaux il y a des gens
qui ont honte de par rapport à des
comportements de cette nature là qui ont
manifesté par quelqu'un qui est
enseignant et que ça dure aussi
longtemps que souvent on déplace
l'enseignant faut de pouvoir le
congédier
grave aussi c'est le fait que ça risque
de ternir toute la profession alors la
posture syndicale telle que défendue
madame Hubert c'est non on n'a pas
besoin d'un ordre on est déjà on se
retrouve mais on voit le désarroi des
parents c'est des événements rapportés
qu'ils ont depuis des mois peut-être
même des années ils savent pas vers qui
se tourner alors est-ce qu'il faut
mettre qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire parce
que le protecteur de Level de l'élève
mais protecteur de l'élève soit un ordre
professionnel non non et c'est une
question je fais maintenant
écouter ici on est dans une situation
les extraits qu'on a eu plus on parle
juste des enseignants qui crient mais
j'ai un petit nombre d'enseignants qui
sont incompétents au niveau de la
possibilité d'enseigner un tout petit
non mais ils sont là et si votre enfant
est avec un enseignant de ce groupe ces
enseignants alors une de ces enseignants
là écoutez ça pose des dégâts importants
et dans le cas dans les cas qu'on a
entendu et que personne est réagi ça
c'est comme ne pas porter assistance à
personne en danger c'est des jeunes de
six ans votre patron madame Dussault un
de vos patrons vous aurez abordé et
inverse et redonner ce genre de
commentaires là envers vous
ça devient dangereux moi je suis une
adolescente je sais pas moi de 13 14 ans
je suis déjà anxieux jardin déjà
certains difficultés importantes
environnement où ça crie et même s'écrit
pas après moi l'agression verbale de
Jean à côté de moi écoutez dans certains
cas ça peut devenir carrément dangereux
par rapport à des gens qui sont plus
vulnérables que d'autres donc c'était
totalement totalement inacceptable et on
peut pas dire que c'est un contrat de
travail ou l'application une convention
collective qui est bordélique ce type de
problème là commenter la discussion vous
avez entendu la promesse de monsieur
Legault le rejet par Monsieur Drainville
vous avez parlé de lobby au début alors
à partir de toutes ces révélations là
depuis quelques jours que faut-il
engager comme recherche de solutions
mon plan B parce qu'il y aura un plan B
qui est pas mon meilleur selon moi c'est
carrément de créer une association
professionnelle des enseignants des
enseignants du Québec qui s'occuperaient
des conditions qui détermineraient les
conditions d'admission d'exercice les
conditions d'évaluation et surtout au
niveau de surveillance spinale mais pas
une organisation syndicale c'est
vraiment comme l'Association des
médecins spécialistes du Québec ou un
autre type d'association professionnelle
ce serait moins puissant qu'on a
professionnelle mais écoutez mais on
pourra pas éternellement moi mon dossier
remonte à 30 ans le dessus
c'est toujours la même la fin de non
recevoir syndicale alors que c'est pas
une question syndicale c'est une
question de protection du public
quand on est victime d'un avocat d'un
comptable on porte plein directement au
syndic de cet ordre professionnel
dans justement dans les conditions de
travail l'environnement les faits les
positions sont embrunnables ou exténuées
etc prenez mon exemple vous faites
apostrophie de la manière que je viens
de décrire un de vos patrons vous dites
écoutez bah là il doit être fatigué et
puis on va lui donner sa chance on va
l'aider il y a comme une limite au
niveau des comportements acceptable
certains enseignants ne sont plus en
état d'enseigné pendant une certaine
période et dans ces cas-là dans certains
de ses collègues il faudrait suspendre
le permis d'enseigner et fournir de
l'aide je mets quoi mais avoir des
exigences au niveau de la formation qui
doivent aller rechercher avant de
continuer à avant de revenir à la
pratique ce qu'on va dans la majorité
des professions
même pas au courant tant que ça la
situation
alors on va voir les prochains gestes du
gouvernement dernière petite réponse
quelques secondes qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire à l'endroit de ces élèves là
actuellement ce qu'on invite les gens à
dénoncer en ce moment est-ce qu'on
invite ce qu'on fait un soutien
psychologique à ses enfants de première
année qui ont subi ça parce que
généralement en présence d'un adulte
attentif affectueux et par rapport à
certains jeunes qui étaient nettement
plus vulnérables ça pourrait amener une
forme d'accompagnement mais chose
certaine je conclue comme ça quand vous
êtes rendus à déposer des plaintes à la
police et envoyer des enregistreuses
nous apparaît dans l'enregistrement dans
les sacs d'école pour être capable de
protéger des enfants dites moi pas qu'on
a pas besoin de d'avoir une forme
d'organisation professionnelle pour
encadrer l'enseignement
québecue on était heureux de vous
recevoir encore une fois l'émission Ce
soir bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI